the first 10 minutes of this movie were
no joke better than the entire last film
heads exploded dreams came true the
Expendables 2 starring everyone if you
saw the first movie and you enjoyed the
first movie then there is absolutely no
doubt in my mind that you are going to
like this movie if you didn't like the
first movie there's a very strong
possibility that you will like this one
quite a bit more because the actors like
this in a movie like this this movie
needs to be a cheese fest of Awesomeness
and the first one took itself way too
seriously this film took all the
problems the first one had and made it
better and made it more fun too
Expendables 2 is directed by Simon West
he made this little slice of heaven oh
yeah Stallone directed the first movie
but here Simon West is clearly a better
director of action he gets a lot of wide
angles you can see the actors doing
their stunts you can you can tell what's
going on it's filming that classic style
you know that 80s action style it's not
just in your face shaky-cam like this
new style of today none of that in this
movie lots of Steadicam operating action
I was so glad to see that now you may be
thinking hey Chris aren't you gonna tell
us about the plot or anything no I'm not
there's a bad guy his name is
jean-claude van Damme and he's awesome
there's a team of good guys there called
The Expendables and they're awesome and
they're gonna fight because there's some
kind of plutonium or something and
there's people and they want to save
them it doesn't matter this is an action
movie at its very core and nothing more
in this film knows that it is self-aware
thank goodness this film is so
self-aware of itself and
self-deprecating of itself these are
actors who aren't really playing
characters they're kind of playing
versions of the Hollywood persona that
the public has of them when you make a
movie like this okay and you got all
these people in or all these awesome
people you can't make a film that is
like serious you just you can't do it
and if you try it's not gonna be good
this film knows that and it does it so
well and it's everything I wanted it to
be yes the plot is stupid yes the
dialogue is at times awful and some of
the acting is horrendously bad I don't
care I knew that going in did I really
expect Dolph Lundgren to pull an Academy
award-winning performance out of this
movie no I didn't and yeah he's not good
but he is awesome you know these guys
are awesome there's a nostalgia level
here
with this movie that comes with this
this material and you feel it in this
movie you can feel these characters
coming together it's just fun to see all
these little things fit into place for
you like yes this reminds me of my
childhood Oh
oh yeah that reminds me my oh yes
jean-claude dam just kicked a guy in the
face my day is complete my balls have
just dropped even more thank you for
that and you know what else I really
liked about this movie was the fact that
the villain in this movie was actually
good jean-claude van Damme as the
villain he was really good in the movie
yeah some of his lines I couldn't
understand what he was saying
same thing with Dolph Lundgren same
thing with Stallone and some other
people as well because in the first
Expendables that villain was so weak
just like some guy in a suits I'm old
like 55 year old guy of course that's
pretty much the median age of everyone
in this movie but whatever the villain
from the first one is a week that's what
I'm saying in the second film
jean-claude Van Damme he brings the
money good villain
you did a good job my friend it is so
much fun to see Swardson Tiger back in
this movie just toting a gun and doing
all these quippy one-liners back and
forth pitched he's great he's going to
this movie I was thinking Liam Hemsworth
why are you in this movie you don't
really fit in with all these classic
action stars most of the many ways some
of them are newer from today's but I was
just thinking Liam Hemsworth I don't
know and he was a really strong point of
this movie his character was important
to the film and I thought he did a
really good job in the movie I was
impressed with him as well it's really
nice to see Statham doing his thing this
movie - because I'm a huge Jason Statham
fan he has a really good chemistry with
Stallone like they work really well
together you can tell their buddies in
real life I just like how all these
actors have this camaraderie with one
another you know it's really cool to see
them work together some actors come in
and come out and you can tell that they
were just kind of there because they are
contractually obligated to at least
appear in a few scenes something I
really loved about this movie was the
addition of Chuck Norris's character in
the way they treated him they understand
that although Chuck Norris didn't really
make any like excellent films they
understand the persona that has now been
developed around him that he is like
this ghostly assassin that can do
anything and they really exploited that
for the better and he had some of the
funniest moments in the whole movie he
had one moment which the audience was
just dying and actually laughed
continuously on to the next scene and I
didn't know what anyone was staying for
like half the next scene because
everyone was still dying at this joke it
was great as I've said a thousand times
this movie has a ton of problems the
acting is atrocious at times the
dialogue is terrible it's a giant
cliched mess everyone in the movie has a
gun
everyone knows how to shoot the gun
everyone knows how to use their fists
their feet their knives everything and
it's just a lot of fun to watch because
it's made well it's directed well it has
a lot of charisma you can tell these
actors are excited for this material
just to be there and to be part of this
camaraderie with one another it's a big
dumb movie but were you really expecting
anything else all I wanted from this
movie was for it to be self-aware of
itself and it was and it worked I'm
going to give the Expendables to a B+ as
an action film it is just a lot of fun
just go and have fun movie it's a really
good time I enjoyed the film looking
forward to the third one let me know
what you thought Expendables two below
it or even the first film what you guys
think and as always thanks for watching
guys and if you liked this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck my eyes
[Music]